dans le nord de la france la situation
des exilés a atteint un point critique à
grande synthe dans la zone du puythouck
un camp de migrants d'environ 350
personnes subit des évacuations à
répétition jusqu'à deux par semaine
après l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre et d'une société de nettoyage
les tentes sont lacérés et emporté les
affaires mises à labenne oussouye et
certains exilés sont mises à l'abri dans
des centres les autres hommes femmes et
enfants errent dans la boue en plein
hiver dans un camp sans sanitaires des
actions supervisé par la nouvelle
municipalité qui inquiète les associatif
très actif sur la zone hier ya une
grosse évacuation ça faisait une semaine
qu'elle n'avait pas eu c'est peut-être
pour ça donc il ya eu deux compagnies
différentes de crs mobilisés d'habitude
en a qu'une notre équipe a été entouré
et ils ont été filmés ils ont été pris
en photo par les forces de l'ordre avec
et sans masque
ils ont pu bouger qu'à la fin de la fin
de l'évacuation aller voir un petit peu
ce qui avait été fait mais on vraiment
ils ont vraiment pas pu observer en 2021
il ya des gens qui vivent dans les bois
quoi il ya des gens qui vivent dans la
boue on demande aux pouvoirs publics
qu'ils agissent comme il aurait dû le
faire depuis longtemps
bibeau szendy un des exilés originaire
du kurdistan irakien
présent dans le camp depuis un an et
demi raconte ces évacuations
il est traduit par un associatif donc il
dit qu' ils viennent et viana par contre
ils lui disent allez faut partir et
prennent cette affaire et il n'a pas
tort de récupérer quoi que ce soit que
j'ai déjà tout ça va très très vite et
il est privé que tout le temps il doit
dormir mais
et toujours faire attention donc le
matin ils viennent pas pour effet de
partir avant eux
il aspire à gagner la grande-bretagne
pays où il était plus simple jusqu'ici
d'obtenir des papiers et du travail lui
son quotidien c'est de dormir une heure
ou deux par nuit parce que la part de la
police vienne ils doivent attendre la
journée à avoir à manger de recharger
leur téléphone
voilà son quotidien c'est de rester ici
d'attendre cars and lui aussi kurdes
d'irak explique qu'il a fui son pays
pour des raisons politiques et subit
aujourd'hui une situation dramatique
c'est dur psychologiquement à vivre
quand surtout quand il pleut qu'ils
arrachaient tentes et qu'on n'est même
pas encore sorti de deux de nos tentes
et on peut même rien récupéré ils
s'indignent d'une situation aussi cruel
qu'il logique c'est vraiment difficile
surtout pour les familles de rester ici
et en dessin l'espoir c'est que les
personnes et font passer les parfums
différents scellés font pas faire
l'angleterre
alertée par cette situation délétère les
eurodéputés verts karima delli et damien
carême ont fait le déplacement
ce dernier ancien maire de grande synthe
est connu pour s'être dressés contre
l'état pour offrir des conditions
d'accueil plus digne aux exilés mais la
nouvelle municipalité ne suit pas cette
voie
sur place les visiteurs sont choqués on
voit bien que les évacuations il y en a
une je crois 85,87 l'année dernière ne
servent à rien mais ça fait des années
qu'on le dit ayant un minimum de
d'humanité dans notre action politique
dans l'action publique en france
en permettant à ces personnes de vivre
dignement et pas comme des animaux quand
danser sous bois c'est une stratégie de
l'état d'un visibiliser le problème en
essayant de départ plié il joue aussi
sur l'épuisement des associations et et
l'europe et ne joue pas son rôle de
solidarité ne joue pas son jeu de
solidarité et les états membres se
recroqueville derrière des postures
extrémistes il ya quand même un cadre
légal on n'a pas le droit dans une
collectivité de laisser des gens comme
ça on voit médecins du monde qui nous
disent qu'à la galicie la gale elle peut
se répandre à toute la population donc
la collectivité doit prendre des mesures
pour empêcher l'épidémie dont cadre de
la loi respecter un rapport de
chercheurs notent que certains pays
d'europe ont recours à la détention
illégale des exilés et alors
les températures baissent la politique
migratoire européenne et française
continue à patiner au détriment de la
dignité des exilés